le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question au nom du groupe socialiste
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale depuis hier des
milliers d'écoliers reprennent
progressivement le chemin de l'école
tandis que bon nombre reste chez eux
vous le savez monsieur le ministre
l'inquiétude est grande parmi les
enseignants les parents les enfants mais
aussi les décideurs locaux bien souvent
des protocoles sanitaires sont
difficilement applicables et ce malgré
toute la bonne volonté et le dévouement
des personnels municipaux et de
l'éducation nationale le conseil
scientifique lui même estimé que cette
rentrée si particulière était prématurée
face au danger épidémique toujours actif
et devant l'impossibilité d'assurer des
règles sanitaires satisfaisantes
certains maires ont pris la lourde
décision de ne pas rouvrir leurs écoles
souhaitant au mieux protéger leurs
populations
c'est notamment le cas en seine et marne
où quelques communes ont décidé ainsi
qui de plus compétent que le maire pour
juger de la faisabilité ou non d'une
réouverture les élus qui ont fait ce
choix dans un contexte bien précis ne
l'ont pas fait pour des raisons
politiciennes mais en responsabilité
vis-à-vis des capacités de leurs
bâtiments des effectifs à leur
disposition et des protections
nécessaires
or certaines académies ont clairement
fait comprendre à ses élus que leur
choix entraînerait des conséquences
fâcheuses
les enfants des personnels soignants n'y
serait plus accueillis et aucun
enseignement enseignants ne seraient
disponibles pour assurer l'éducation de
ses enfants
voilà de quoi forcer la main aux édiles
réfractaires ce n'était pas une
coquetterie de leur part monsieur le
ministre
s'il ne rouvre par leur école c'est
qu'ils estiment que les conditions ne
sont pas réunies et qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts pour une réouverture immédiate
alors monsieur ministre dans ce cas
particulier allez vous maintenir de
surcroît dans des zones classées rouge
une offre spécifique pour les enfants de
personnel soignant et travailler de
manière apaisée avec les élus afin de
trouver des solutions adaptées pour
chaque territoire
pour vous répondre la parole est obligé
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur joël
bigot il ya plusieurs éléments dans
votre question et je vais évidemment y
répondre d'abord je déduis de votre
introduction que vous êtes contre
déconfinement scolaire et que vous
souhaitez l'ouverture en septembre
je pense qu'il faut que vous assumiez ce
que vous dites c'est à dire que ça
signifie que vous pensez que des élèves
les enfants peuvent rester chez eux
notamment des enfants jeunes de l'âge de
l'école primaire jusqu'au mois de
septembre avec des conséquences sociales
sanitaires sociétal que nous sommes en
train de voir en ce moment même donc
vous êtes en droit de reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir une préoccupation
sociale plus forte que la vôtre mais en
tout cas elle est là le gouvernement
veut que les enfants retrouvent l'école
parce que l'école de la république
ça n'est pas secondaire l'école de la
république c'est fondamental et c'est
fondamental
en période normale c'est encore plus
fondamentale en période de crise
à condition évidemment d'avoir un
protocole sanitaires strictes vous me
reprocher un protocole sanitaire strict
jeu l'assument
est ce que ça signifie que vous voudriez
qu'ils ne soient pas stricte non il est
stricte et en effet il est exigeant ils
exigent pour nous tous mais quand il ya
une crise on se retrousse les manches
ensemble et on respecte justement ce qui
permet de garantir la santé
c'est ce que nous faisons et je m'en
réjouis car il ya une forte coopération
entre les maires et l'éducation
nationale la preuve en est plus de 90%
des communes au moment où je vous parle
réouvre leur école donc nous y arrivons
bien sûr c'est difficile
bien sûr ça exige du travail c'est
évident si le virus correspondent à une
période facile ça se saurait mais dans
les périodes de crise chacun doit
montrer collectivement que on est
capable de surmonter les obstacles et de
travailler ensemble et avec vous je
rends hommage au maire parce que en
effet l'immense majorité des maires
s'est retroussé les manches avec les
personnels des collectivités locales
avec ceux de l'éducation nationale et si
ce qui permet à un million cinq cent
mille élèves aujourd'hui de retrouver
l'école évidemment voudrait que ce soit
encore plus mais c'est justement ce qui
va se passer au cours des prochaines
semaines
alors pour vous répondre directement oui
bien sûr nous avons vocation à
accueillir les enfants des personnels
soignants y compris en zone rouge
je rectifierai ce qu'il faut si c'est
nécessaire mais bien sûr nous les
accueillerons
et nous avons pu les accueillir pendant
la période de confinement sans qu'il ait
eu de problème particulier
c'est donc bien la preuve que c'est
possible et qu'avec la volonté politique
on peut avoir la volonté sociale
je vous remercie